five things five things that I think you
think that an emotional Outlet what else
emotional
Outlet loving genius I think they want a
mother they want a mother mhm I think
they want I do I will go as far and stay
say stability I think they do want
stability I I I know they do silly
things but I do need down believe they
want stability somewhere what's what's
one skill that a girl would have to have
or like trait what you for a man yeah
for a man that like what would he value
don't say I rning do you know what
today's days I'm just going to say it
being be his mother be his mother that's
what men want get of this book listen
whoever you this is the most delusional
I've ever heard in my life you are
describing a child